the talent you know that our industry
represents is inspiring to me and so the
three people that were honoring all have
you know what they've done in there like
a seasoned amazing and the people who we
honor some of them who have never gotten
an Oscar some who have they've done
things to us over our lifetime moved us
in different ways and now we get a
chance to honor them on what we like to
believe this a third year is the
beginning of Oscar season you know let
the games begin three wonderful you know
he'd be an honor can i buy the Academy
so it is and really great to be here and
deservingly so and as a governor I'm so
proud of these awards I think it's one
of the best awards of the whole season
because there's a chance for us to
really take time and really celebrate
these amazing people and we have three
amazing award winners tonight and I'm so
excited I mean you know these are people
that we grew up with and we grew up with
his fans and you know we grew up sort of
you know being inspired by what they do
so now we're here in a position that I
feel very honored to be in terms of
celebrating that living yeah I think
it's a very good thing for the Academy I
it's my first one so I'm
I'm looking forward to it I'm intrigued
yeah it's just it's kind of an amazing
night there's so many people I just want
to meet and stare head for a while you
know it's really exciting to see people
all dressed up for a wonderful occasion
and Oscar standing tall in the
background I mean hello I'm going to go
and rush him he's kind of cute it's
pretty exciting it just shows you that
these events are global that these three
people are being represented night oslo
by cons and therefore you know in that
vein whoa comes to hair when we do
something we try to do it right and i
think this knife its third year you'll
see once again it's going to be done
right and it'll be great
you